frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir beraten in dieser
Woche den zweiten regulären
Bundeshaushalt nach der sogenannten
Zeitenwende nach alledem was wir bisher
dazu gehört und gelesen haben wird auch
der Bundeshaushalt für das Jahr 2024
dieser fundamentalen Herausforderung
einer tatsächlichen Zeitenwende nicht
gerecht
in der Bewertung des
völkerrechtswidrigen russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine sind
wir uns hier im Haus ist auf ganz links
und da ganz rechts ja weitgehend einig
wir sind es jedenfalls vordergründig
und in der gemeinsam Verurteilung dieses
Angriffskrieges
aber ich habe erhebliche Zweifel ob wir
die ganze Dimension dieses Krieges und
seine weitreichenden Auswirkungen auch
übereinstimmend richtig einschätzen
stellen wir uns einen kurzen Augenblick
vor der Krieg wäre und so hoffen wir es
ja alle morgen zu Ende
ist dann am Tag danach alles wieder so
wie vor dem Krieg könnten wir einfach da
weitermachen wo wir vorher aufgehört
haben das mag mancher hier im Saal so
annehmen aber meine Damen und Herren die
ganze Dimension dieser zeitenwände durch
den Krieg wird erst nach dem Krieg
richtig sichtbar werden wir sind eben
nicht nur Zeitzeugen dieses Krieges wir
sind ob wir das nun wollen oder nicht
auch Zeitzeugen der Zerstörung einer
ganzen Friedens und freiheitsordnung und
je nachdem wie der Krieg ausgeht ob also
die gewaltsame Aneignung eines Fremden
Territoriums durch eine nuklear macht
mehr oder weniger erfolgreich verläuft
wird es weitere Versuche geben
imperialer vermutlich ebenfalls nuklear
bewaffneter Staaten in ihrer
Nachbarschaft mit militärischer Gewalt
territoriale zugewöhnung zu erzielen
deshalb bleibt auf absehbare und
möglicherweise auf sehr lange Zeit die
Sicherung des Friedens und vor allem die
Sicherung unserer Freiheit die
wichtigste staatliche Aufgabe unseres
Landes in der Europäischen Union und vor
allem in der Natur
vor diesem Hintergrund war es richtig
dass sie ihr Bundeskanzler in ihrer
Regierungserklärung vom 27 Februar des
letzten Jahres versprochen haben ab
sofort zwei Prozent unserer
Wirtschaftsleistung in die Bundeswehr zu
investieren und ein zusätzliches
schuldenfinanziertes Sondervermögen von
100 Milliarden Euro für die Beschaffung
großer langjährig zu finanzierender
Waffensysteme für unsere Streitkräfte zu
errichten wir haben wie Sie wissen diese
Entscheidung aus Überzeugung zugestimmt
Geschäftsgrundlage unserer Zustimmung
war allerdings das so wie sie es hier
versprochen haben der Verteidigungsetat
tatsächlich auf zwei Prozent anwächst
stattdessen sehen wir jetzt einen
weitgehend unveränderten
Verteidigungsetat der immer stärker von
zusätzlichen Personal und Sachkosten
beansprucht und zur rein formalen
Erfüllung des 2% Ziels bedienen sie sich
für den laufenden Betrieb
zunehmend aus dem Sondervermögen das
schon in wenigen Jahren aufgebraucht
sein wird und spätestens im Jahr 2027
klafft dann eine Lücke von mindestens 30
Milliarden Euro im Verteidigungshaushalt
von der sie heute am Tag keinen Gedanken
und keine Ahnung haben wie sie diese
Lücke denn füllen wollen
ich muss es leider so sagen
trotz ihrer Regierungserklärung und
trotz des Beifalls den sie dafür im
ganzen Haus bekommen haben bei SPD und
Grünen bleibt das ungeliebte Kind
Bundeswehr schon in kurzer Zeit wieder
weitgehend strukturell unterfinanziert
sehr viel weitreichender übrigens als zu
dem Zeitpunkt zu dem sie vor zwei Jahren
die Bundeswehr übernommen haben
großer Verlierer dieser
Verteidigungspolitik und diese
Haushaltspolitik sind sie Herr Pistorius
der sie angetreten sind mit dem
Versprechen mindestens 10 Milliarden
Euro für den laufenden Betrieb der
Bundeswehr mehr zu bekommen sie bekommen
nichts Verlierer sind aber nicht nur Sie
persönlich
sondern Verlierer sind die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten der Bundeswehr Verlierer
ist das Vertrauen der ganzen
Bundesrepublik Deutschland im Bündnis
der NATO und bei uns europäischen
Partner
der Bundesfinanzminister in seiner
einbringungsrede gestern
interessanterweise genau auf diesen
Sachverhalt und auf weitere große
Risiken der nächsten Jahre hingewiesen
hinter dem Horizont so hat er gesagt
auch wenn er heute morgen nicht anwesend
ist warte ein großer Eisberg auf dem wir
zusteuerten und er seinen Kurs nicht
verändern werde also so hat er gesagt
müssten wir unseren Kurs ändern wenn es
nicht zu einer Kollision bekommt
das war dann die Stelle an ihrer Rede
der Bundesfinanzminister ihre
eisbergrede von der an Sie nur noch den
Beifall ihrer eigenen Fraktion bekommen
haben und in deren weiteren Verlauf
gleich drei Bundesminister der Grünen
Frau bärbock Herr Habeck und herr
Özdemir demonstrativ die Regierungsbank
verlassen haben
spätestens seit gestern
spätestens seit gestern haben wir also
zwei Oppositionsführer in Deutschland
einen im Parlament und einen in der
Regierung auf gute Zusammenarbeit
Christian Lindner
der Bundesfinanzminister hat in dieser
eisbergrede berechtigter Weise auch
einige Fragen an uns gestellt wie wir
denn mit diesen Herausforderungen
umgehen würden lassen Sie mich darauf
einige wenige Antworten geben in der
Kürze der Zeit einige wenige aber schon
schon aus unserer Sicht jedenfalls
wichtige die ganz grundsätzliche Antwort
lautet zunächst die Zeitenwende kann
sich nicht in einer Schulden
finanzierten übergangsfinanzierung der
Bundeswehr erschöpfen das ist nicht die
Zeiten denn
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition
sie hätten in ihrer Koalition im letzten
Jahr den Koalitionsvertrag auf die Seite
legen müssen und die gesamten
Prioritäten vor allem der Aufgaben der
Ausgaben neu ordnen müssen stattdessen
versprechen sie der Bevölkerung es könne
während und nach dem Krieg alles so
weitergehen wie bisher teilweise erhöhen
sie sogar die konstruktiven Ausgaben
noch ohne die Folgen abzuschätzen und
einzuordnen ja das ist genau der Eisberg
den ihn Christian Lindner gestern hier
beschrieben hat und auf den wir
zusteuern das ist genau der Eisberg
meine Damen und Herren
was müssen daraus beschlussförderung
gezogen werden zunächst unser Land
erstickt in Bürokratie wir würden sofort
alle Gesetze stoppen wir würden sofort
alle Gesetze stoppen die diesen
wahnsinnigen Bürokratie Aufwand immer
noch weiter erhöhen dazu zählen eben das
angekündigte Kinder
Grundsicherungsgesetz dass wir bis heute
nicht haben und das Gebäude
Energiegesetz wir würden es nicht machen
und in diesem in dieser Woche hier noch
durchsetzen wollen
das Gebäude Energiegesetz ist übrigens
ein gutes Stichwort wir würden im
Gebäudesektor wie im Verkehrssektor auf
echte
technologieoffenheit setzen es ist doch
keine Überraschung meine Damen und
Herren dass sie mit ihrer Verbotspolitik
auch im zweiten Jahr in Folge die
Klimaziele verfehlen ihre Klimapolitik
ihre Klimapolitik
wird von den Menschen im Land
mehrheitlich nicht mehr mitgetragen weil
die Menschen ist einfach leid sind nur
noch mit Verboten Regulierungen und
kalkulierbaren Kosten und bürokratischen
Auflagen konfrontiert zu werden wenn man
den Klima schaden will dann muss man es
genau so machen wie sie es gegenwärtig
machen genau so
wir würden wir würden das sogenannte
Bürgergeld so ausgestalten dass sich
Arbeit mehr lohnt als der Bezug von
staatlichen Transferleistungen
ich verstehe dass sie hier sehr nervös
reagieren aber das ist doch die Wahrheit
die wir im Augenblick sehen die Menschen
gehen nicht zurück in die Beschäftigung
weil sie sich ausrechnen können dass sie
mit staatlichen Transferleistungen am
Ende des Jahres mehr herausbekommen als
wenn sie in einer einfachen
Beschäftigung arbeiten und
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge und Steuern
bezahlen
wir würden dem älteren Beschäftigten
meine Damen und Herren einen Anreiz
geben eben nicht in die Frühverrentung
zu gehen sondern dem Arbeitsmarkt länger
zur Verfügung zu stehen sie machen davon
genau das Gegenteil
sie reden über Fachkräfte Einwanderung
und lassen es zu dass 260.000 Menschen
vorzeitig in den Altersruhestand gehen
nur damit das hier klar ist weil ich das
hier unter Koalition höre das sind nicht
die Menschen die zu faul sind die
Menschen
können im Gegensatz zu manchen von ihnen
wie können rechnen
4 Tage Woche früh Verhandlung
Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren das
Problem sind nicht die Menschen die das
in Anspruch nehmen die ist das Problem
sind sie die das ermöglichen und die die
politischen Rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen dass das so ist dass sich
Leistung nicht mehr lohnt
wir würden an den Grenzen zu Polen zur
Tschechischen Republik und auch zur
Schweiz ja nicht neue Schlagbäume
errichten aber wir würden die beständig
weiter ansteigende Zahl der illegalen
Grenzübertritte so kontrollieren wie
dies bereits
so kontrollieren wie dies bereits seit
2015 an der Grenze zu Österreich
stattfindet was ist eigentlich der
Unterschied zum Grenzübertritt in
Tschechien in Österreich in der Schweiz
oder aus Polen was ist eigentlich der
Unterschied
danke dass Sie hier sind heute morgen
frau Kaiser vielleicht erläutern Sie uns
mal in den nächsten Tagen was eigentlich
der Unterschied ist nachdem sie sich
gestern krank gemeldet haben und in
Wiesbaden dpa Interviews gegeben haben
schön dass Sie hier sind und vielleicht
sagen Sie mal etwas zu diesem
Sachverhalt und zu diesem illegalen
grenzüberschritten
ja ich verstehe dass ihm das unangenehm
ist aber sie haben ja einen
Koalitionspartner der bis zum heutigen
Tag beharrlich bestreitet dass es
überhaupt
illegale Migration gibt wenn Sie einen
solchen Koalitionspartner haben dann
kommen sie natürlich nicht zu einer
Lösung dieses Problem das aber
mittlerweile unsere Gesellschaft tief
spaltet und dass uns demnächst Brot und
die Ohren zu fliegen wenn sie ist nicht
lösen meine Damen und Herren
und dann könnten wir und dann könnten
wir auch einmal über die Aufgaben und
Aufgabenverteilung zwischen Bund und
Ländern und Gemeinden miteinander reden
aber erst bitte nachdem Sie dieses
Problem gelöst haben und dafür gesorgt
haben dass Länder und Gemeinden nicht
übergebühr mit diesen Problemen belastet
werden ganz interessant der
Bundesfinanzminister hat ja erstmalig in
diesem Jahr einen Bericht anfertigen
lassen über die Leistungen des Bundes
zur Mitfinanzierung von Länder und
kommunalaufgaben herausgekommen im
August 2023 er kommt dabei auf einen
Betrag von 56 Milliarden Euro den der
Bund ausgibt für Aufgaben die eigentlich
länderaufgaben und kommunalaufgaben sind
wir haben in unseren Berechnungen nicht
ganz diesen Betrag erreicht wir liegen
bei ungefähr 40 Milliarden Euro aber
immerhin das ist doch eine Summe aus der
sich heraus das Potenzial ergibt die
eine Neuverteilung der Aufgaben zwischen
Bund und Ländern jetzt vorgenommen
werden müsste meine Damen und Herren und
wenn wir das dann täten wenn sie das
alles machen würden
dann hätten wir auch schnell Spielräume
die z.B für eine größere Steuerreform in
Deutschland gebraucht würden wir könnten
dann endlich den Soli abschaffen
das würde vor allem den
mittelständischen Unternehmen in
Deutschland schnell und wirksam helfen
aber das wollen sie nicht weil sie
natürlich in ihrer ganzen Klassenkampf
Rhetorik immer nur von den Reichen und
den breiten Schultern sprechen die sie
meinen immer noch mehr belasten zu
müssen das Gegenteil wäre richtig gerade
auch im Interesse der kleinen und
mittleren Unternehmen die weitgehend
Personengesellschaften sind in
Deutschland wir könnten dann
so wie die FDP das ja wohl auch will wir
könnten dann für Personengesellschaften
und Kapitalgesellschaften in Deutschland
eine einheitliche Unternehmenssteuer
einführen die vor allem reinvestierte
Gewinne mit maximal 25% belastet das
wären international wettbewerbsfähige
Steuersätze und dann könnten wir sogar
in der in den Einkommensteuertarif in so
gestalten dass sich Leistung wirklich
wieder lohnt aber der
Einkommensteuertarif daneben nur und
ausschließlich für die privaten
Einkünfte herangezogen wird das wäre mal
ein Steuerkonzept wo sich Leistung lohnt
und wo die Attraktivität des
investitionsstandorts und
arbeitsstandort Deutschland wirklich
schnell und nachhaltig gesteigert werden
könnte
und da jetzt da er jetzt da ist da er
jetzt angekommen ist Herr Lindner im
Sinne einer guten Zusammenarbeit würde
ich sie gerne bitten nicht auf das
hereinzufallen was vom Generalsekretär
SPD in den letzten Tagen dazu
veröffentlicht worden ist das hat mit
unseren steuerpolitischen Vorstellungen
nichts gar nichts zu tun das sind nicht
unsere steuerpolitischen Vorstellung
sie sehen also meine Damen und Herren
wir diskutieren hier nicht nur über die
Details des Bundeshaushaltes wie wir
widersprechen ihnen in ihrem ganz
grundsätzlichen Staatsverständnis sie
bauen nämlich
trotz zeitenwände den betreuenden
bevormundenden alles regulierenden und
dann auch finanzierenden Staat einen
geradezu paternalistischen Staat immer
weiter aus der möglichst hohe Steuern
einnimmt um sie dann nach Abzug eines
immensen Verwaltungsapparates den sie
natürlich am liebsten aus ihren eigenen
Reihen besetzen mit ihm Menschen Kosten
aus diesem Apparat dann gönnerhaft an
die Bevölkerung nach ihren
parteipolitischen Vorstellungen wieder
einen Teil davon zurückzugeben das ist
der Staat den Sie gerne hätte
und es ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
der Bundeskanzler sie werden das nicht
so ganz gerne hören aber sie haben mal
als Generalsekretär der SPD von der
Lufthoheit über den Kinderbetten
gesprochen die die SPD erreichen müssen
sie sind auf diesem Weg ein ganzes Stück
vorangekommen und Kindergrundsicherung
ist genau das was Sie erreichen wollen
Lufthoheit
und Familien über dieser Gesellschaft
damit Sie sie nach ihren eigenen
Vorstellungen gestalten können das ist
das was sie wollen
wir
ja ich kann ja verstehen dass sie das
alles nicht gerne hören aber meine Damen
und Herren es gibt eben einen wirklich
grundlegenden Unterschied zwischen Ihnen
und uns wir wollen wir wollen ja danke
für den Beifall bestätigt genau das was
ich jetzt sagen möchte wir wollen
nämlich den Menschen den Unternehmen und
vor allem den Ingenieurinnen und
Ingenieuren in unserem Land etwas
zutrauen wir wollen sie zur Leistung und
zur gemeinsamen Gestaltung unseres
Landes wirklich ermutigen und befähigen
sie tun von fast alledem genau das
Gegenteil sie tun genau das Gegenteil
und wenn die Menschen dann am Ende des
Monats auf ihre Lohn- und
Gehaltsabrechnung schauen und Sie sehen
welche Steuern und Abzüge sie dazu
bezahlen haben und gleichzeitig hören
was sie ohne Arbeit in diesem Land auch
bekommen könnten wenn sie dann
anschließend Monate lang auf einen
Arzttermin warten und keine Kitaplätze
für die Kinder bekommen ja hat dann
entsteht eben genau diese Stimmung im
Land die wir heute haben Herr
Bundeskanzler beschweren sie sich nicht
über die Stimmung das ist genau die
Stimmung die sie mit ihrer Koalition in
Deutschland herbeiführen und daran
müssen sie grundlegend etwas ändern wenn
sich in diesem Land zum besseren etwas
wenden soll
Friedrich Merz der Oppositionsführer der
fraktions- und Parteichef der CDU und
CSU erhält hier viel beifahrt aus seinen
ryanair hat die Generaldebatte eröffnet
und wie nicht anders zu erwarten mit
seinem Lieblingsthema nämlich der
Unterfinanzierung der Bundeswehr sie
bekommen nix obwohl boris pistorisch hat
ja 10 Milliarden zusätzlich gefordert
die Bundeswehr das ist der einzige Etat
der steigt unter Christian Lindner und
die Bundeswehr bekommt 1,7 Milliarden
Euro mehr das 2 % Ziel allerdings ist
nur zu halten da auch die
finanzierungsprojekte aus dem 100
Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen
angerechnet werden das wird in Zukunft
sehr schwierig werden wenn diese Etat
aufgebraucht ist hat März gesagt die
Eisberge hatte noch mal bemüht die auch
gestern Linda angesprochen hat und dann
hat natürlicher märz das getan was ein
oppositionsgeschäft tut er hat gesagt
der Haushalt
er finanziert viel zu viel soziale
Wohltaten und die Gegenrechnung die
kommt noch